okay uh welcome back everyone uh
good afternoon i am going to uh speak
today about
gauges
oops
uh so this is a this is a rather
advanced topic if you if you go and look
at any textbook on gauge theory
uh you'll see probably that the
pre-requisites include not only group
theory but representation theory
uh
differential geometry or topology
and lee algebras lead groups etc in this
lecture i'm not going to go uh into all
these technical things but
i'm going to try to show how this notion
of a gauge which
in its essence is is not that
complicated how that appears uh in
you know real world geometric deep
learning problems uh and how it informs
the design of network architectures
so i'll start with uh quite an extended
section on motivation
uh covering
first the idea of feature fields so this
idea that certain kinds of geometric
data should be thought of as fields
on your domain in the in the previous
lectures we've covered signals on a
domain which you can think of as scalar
functions or vector valued functions uh
on on your domain omega uh in in some
cases uh there's a slightly more general
concept that you should keep in mind
which is called a field
then another motivation for why we need
to to look at this concept of gauges is
if you want to define a kind of
uh generalization of convolution to data
that lives on on manifolds whether it's
a field uh
or just a scalar function
um and uh yeah the the we'll we'll look
at various solutions to that and then
introduce gauge equivalent convolution
uh as a uh as a as a a sort of a general
framework for defining these kinds of uh
uh
convolutions now i do have in this slide
deck also uh a bunch of stuff on the
mathematical theory behind this bundles
gauges and gauge transformation
uh gauge symmetry and equivariance but
um i will not go into that uh in this
lecture i do uh leave them in the slide
deck so for for those of you who are uh
curious about the underlying mathematics
i i recommend to have a have a look
there uh but this will not be uh
part of the lecture or the exam
so
just to um
to right away give you sort of a high
level idea of what we mean by
gauge engaged transformation uh i made
this uh this slide
so the word gauge uh actually comes from
a device that looks somewhat like this
uh it's an indicator uh of a certain
value like let's say a barometer then
measuring the um the air pressure
uh and the gauge
uh tells you the the the value and
clearly the gauge
uh has some kind of has to have some
kind of units right so if you measure
certain one quantity in one unit you'll
get a different value uh than when you
measure the same physical quantity in
different units
and
that's that's uh that would correspond
to different gauges and when you change
from one gauge to another
then the values that describe the
physical quantity will change even
though the underlying physic physical
thing remains the same
now
when you give this concept to
mathematicians they of course
immediately generalize it to higher
dimensions and the concept becomes quite
unrecognizable from the thing that
initially
you know gave us the word gauge
and
so
here what you see on the on the slide is
is a picture of the more general concept
so what do we have here we have a
manifold m in this case a sphere because
that was easy for me to draw but you can
think in general about any kind of
curved or even flat
space for that matter
and on the
on the manifold we see various things so
first of all
we see this green arrow here which could
be a piece of data that we have that we
want to process more generally usually
we'll we'll have data that forms a field
on this manifold meaning at each
position on the manifold
we have such a geometrical quantity like
in this case a vector
um now if we
you know we can picture this and we can
think in our head as as this vector
being somewhere out there uh let's say
it's an actual wind direction somewhere
on earth
uh but if we want to represent it
numerically in our computer uh then we
need to choose a frame of reference
or in other words a gauge
and this frame of reference uh well we
could choose it in various ways and how
we choose this essentially arbitrary
so here uh what i've drawn in addition
is to to this this data here this green
vector is a bunch of coordinate lines so
those are the blue lines for example
that gives you the standard latitude
longitude coordinate frame on the sphere
and then there's another
equally good coordinate
coordinate system for the sphere given
by these red lines
and using a coordinate system you can
identify a point on the manifold
by some numbers but you can also use it
to derive a frame for the tangent space
in which this this vector lives so here
we have our point and we can take two
vectors
the red vectors
sorry i'm getting some pop-ups here
uh the red vectors
uh that are going in the direction
of the uh of the coordinate lines
okay this is annoying i cannot move my
mouse anymore
my computer is seems to be overheating
anyway the point that i wanted to make
here is that
we can use the coordinate lines to
derive these uh
these basis vectors as you see the red
basis vectors are derived from the red
coordinate system the blue ones from the
blue coordinate system in general you
don't need to do it that way you can
choose an arbitrary coordinate frame at
every point and those are equally good
and for every
coordinate frame that you choose you get
a different numerical representation of
the same geometrical quantity the same
vector in this case so that's what you
see here on the left
and on the right you see the uh the
coordinate charts
with our green vector represented here
as a pair of
numbers ultimately
in this case it's more stretched along
the y axis so maybe this numerical
representation here would be
you know
hi
uh i hope i'm still audible for some
reason uh in my headphones i was getting
a terrible uh noise so i hope we can
just continue like this
uh let me know if i'm not
clearly
audible
anyway uh the
as i was saying we have the same
quantity that has different numerical
representations in the two
uh for the two choices of gauge
and
transforming if if we change the gauge
then we have some transformation of
those numerical quantities and that's
called a gauge transformation
um final thing that's very important to
note here is that
the gauge as you can see is not defined
on the whole manifold necessarily in
this case we have the blue arrows only
in this region here and we have some red
arrows in another region here
and uh that's for good reason as we'll
see but in general you know you have
just these overlapping charts where the
where the gauge is defined and it need
not be defined uh globally
all right so that's the general picture
so why
is this relevant for uh
geometric deep learning applications
so the first
motivation comes from
this this concept of a feature field
so this is a type of data that occurs in
uh in various kinds of applications so
for example if you are looking at
weather data on on earth global weather
data or something coming from a climate
simulation you might have among other
things the
wind direction
everywhere
on earth
so that would give you a vector field
at each point in the space
you have a um
a vector attached uh then another
example is tensor fields
uh so tensor is maybe a
a new or a more
complicated word but in this case it
just means a three by three matrix so
it's a second order
tensor
um and uh what it means is uh so you
have a brain you put it uh in a scanner
and
at every point what the scanner
registers is how much the water diffuses
in the all different directions
that's summarized using this three by
three matrix and if you remember from uh
linear algebra the uh you can think of
the eigenvectors or you can you can
compute from this three by three matrix
a set of eigenvectors and eigenvalues
uh and i can
you can you can visualize that as an
ellipsoid as you see in this picture
where the eigenvectors indicate the
principal uh directions in which the
diffusion happens in the
uh
that's the stretching of the ellipsoid
in different direction or sorry the
orientation of the ellipsoid and then
the eigenvalues give you how much uh the
ellipsoid is stretched or physically
what that means is how much diffusion
there is in that direction
and so this is uh yeah
another example of a field and as we'll
see fields have a particular way of of
transforming um
that's uh that's important and the
physical quantities have to be
represented relative to a frame of
reference or gauge
so that's the first motivation that we
just encountered this kind of data
naturally and in order to represent it
we can only do that
uh relative to a choice of uh gauge
which in many cases is arbitrary
another reason that we might want to
consider these kinds of uh uh
this kind of data uh is that they
can be that fields can be useful as
internal representations in a neural
network so even if your
input data is a scalar signal uh
as we or a
vector-valued signal as we we discussed
in the past
it can be useful to
have internal feature maps that are uh
transform like fields
so one motivation for that
if you remember uh in the lecture on
group convolutions
if we take our scalar signal and we just
apply a group convo solution naively
then the output is a scalar function on
the group g and in some cases that's
fine as in the case of
planar rotations and translations you
have a group with three axes and you can
definitely store feature maps on that on
such a three-dimensional group but in
other cases uh for instance when the
group is the group of permutations of n
nodes then you have n factorial group
elements that's very large or
if you talk about continuous
transformations
group has an infinite number of elements
maybe a potentially large number of
dimensions and so this becomes
computationally infeasible
now there are
alternative approaches that
uh
output scalar functions uh on uh on a
homogeneous space which is lower
dimensional
but this leads to strong constraints on
the on the filters so by having your
internal feature maps uh as fields you
get some
uh intermediate solution where you don't
pay the full computational cost of
storing a feature map on a group
uh and yet you have more expressive
field uh features than uh and filters
than just uh scalars which you get for
scalar fluids
and we'll look at more
more detail
at this in a minute
okay so here uh just uh
uh explain in a bit more detail the
mathematical concept of the field
so so far in this course uh we've only
mainly considered
uh signals that
we modeled as functions on our domain
omega so omega was a graph or a grid
uh or some continuous space maybe a
homogeneous space like the sphere
and then we had some data
that's a function on
omega so at every point you
it returns a set of feature values a
vector in c
c being some vector space with a certain
number of channels
and now the notion of a field is a
slight generalization of the idea of a
function
where
instead of mapping every u to a point or
a vector in the same vector space
you now map it to a vector space that is
associated with the point u
so the most intuitive example of this is
the
is the tangent space so if we have our
manifold again just drawing a sphere
here for simplicity
uh you can consider at every point
the tangent space uh
which is the best linear approximation
to that
and uh the
you know as in the example of uh wind
directions on earth
the
the the wind direction or the the vector
at that point will lie in this tangent
plane at least that's that's how we
model uh
many kinds of data
um and although the tangent planes at
every point are you know they look the
same they're all two-dimensional vector
spaces um there isn't a canonical way to
align all of them and they are really
different spaces and you have to
choose a different basis uh or a
different frame or different gauge also
words for the same thing
for each of those
of the spaces so those spaces uh are
called the fibers
in the in the mathematical theory of
gauge
theory and fiber bundles
and they they can be also more general
uh spaces than just the uh the tangent
plane
again we'll look at more examples of
that
right so i think i've said most of this
so to describe a field as a function we
need to align all of these spaces so
uh
by and we do that by essentially
choosing a basis um then
we can
then the space becomes uh you know
aligned with the standard
two-dimensional uh uh vector space r2
uh in this case of a two-dimensional
tangent uh plane
um
and so that's uh that's another way to
think about this
this issue of choosing a gauge aligning
all of these fibers
all right so we have to choose a gauge
in order to describe a field as a
function
and in some cases there's an obvious
choice and so actually
a lot of the time people don't even know
that they are doing this
and sometimes that leads to problems
in other cases uh
it's it's really um
not uh not obvious how to choose it
so if you have a uh
if your space omega is the plane
uh and you're expressing the points in
the plane using x y coordinates with
some chosen uh you know x and y axis
then it makes sense to just choose to
use that same frame at every point in
the in the manifold and even the the
distinction between the manifold itself
and the plane and its tangent space
which is also the plane becomes blurry
and people forget about uh this
distinction but when you go to a space
like a sphere then things become a bit
more
clear
so here
you know i can choose a frame at one
point uh but uh yeah how should i choose
it uh it's completely arbitrary and then
what it means for uh
the frame at another point to be the
same is also
uh not clear and so here you you're
really faced with this arbitrariness you
just have to choose something and it
will affect how your data is numerically
represented in your computer but in some
sense it's clear that it shouldn't uh
matter and that's why we will get to
gauge equivalence
now there's another uh subtlety
which is that
a global continuous gauge may not even
exist
so
if you have
a continuous signal on your continuous
field
or even a smooth one on your manifold
you would like that the numerical
representation
of that field is also
continuous or smooth and for that you
would like your
choice of frames uh your gauge to be
smooth
and it turns out that such things don't
always exist so here you see a manifold
a torus
which has a property that is called
parallelizable
um
and uh what you see here is a single
vector field which is defined globally
everywhere
and it's also everywhere smooth
um and that could for example constitute
the first basis vector of a uh of a
choice of frame
uh and here on the
uh on the sphere you see an attempt to
do the same namely we want to choose a
vector everywhere
and we want it to its direction to very
smoothly
but we see that at the poles here we get
a singularity so there the
around the poles the orientation changes
very quickly and at the pole there's no
way to choose a direction
uh of your your basis vector uh that is
uh is smooth
um because nearby basis vectors are all
pointing in completely different
directions
and what that would mean is if you if
you use this uh kind of
non-continuous gauge to represent a
continuous
field
then the field would numerically look
discontinuous and that can clearly hurt
the performance of your machine learning
algorithm because it will generalize by
you know assigning similar outputs to
similar looking inputs and similar here
means numerically similar that is unless
you explicitly account for the choice of
gauge so that's quite important to do
all right so the lessons so far uh
geometric data uh
often in form of feature fields
geometric data also comes in the form of
feature fields and these things can only
be represented relative to a choice of
gauge
and in general there's no sort of
natural
way to choose that gauge
so the same field can be represented in
many equivalent ways relative to
different gauges
furthermore in general we cannot even
use a single gauge to represent a
continuous field as a continuous
functions
function
and you need to define your gauge
locally
now i should say that this last point
is mainly a theoretical concern the
mathematicians uh care about this a lot
in in practical applications there are
also ways to
um to uh to use discontinuous gauge
in particular because we discretize our
manifold anyway
okay so now we get to this notion of
a gauge transformation
my computer is again freezing
okay here we are
so gauge transformation i already
mentioned this uh on one of the first
slides
but
here we look at it
again and
and maybe define it a bit more precisely
using mathematics
so what we have on the left
is a choice of gauge uh it's the the
obvious one uh for uh the plane and then
on the right we uh have
a very irregular choice of of gauge but
mathematically equally equally good
um and
as you can see the frames on the left
are
all related to the corresponding frame
on the right by a
rotation
so
the way we can model this is to say a
gauge transformation
is a
function on
our domain omega or more generally on
some subset u of omega that outputs an
element of a group g
which in this case would be the rotation
so this is different from the kind of
global symmetries that we've considered
before
for example uh
our group g could be
you know so3 rotations in three
dimensions uh that we apply to our whole
space omega
but we only have
one we only consider one group element
uh and we apply it to to uh to our
signal on omega here we have uh that the
single
uh the analog of of this group element
is now a function a group valued
function on omega so you have a
different transformation at every point
that's why gates transformation also
sometimes called local
symmetries
now the way that this thing acts on
signals
is just like we saw in previous lectures
is via some kind of representation
so
g is a acts directly on the on the
frames
but if you have say a vector that will
transform in a different way from for
example the tensor as in diffusion
tensor imaging
and yet again different from other kinds
of geometrical quantities so that's why
we introduce this
representation rho
okay so here we look at the example of a
diffusion tensor image
and how that would transform
so
the
diffusion tensor image signal uh is a
function x from r3 that's our uh domain
omega to r three by three that's our
vector space uh c at each point we have
a a 3x3
matrix
and
when we want to
you know rotate the
eigenvectors or rotate the ellipses that
you see here the way to do that is to
conjugate this matrix with a rotation
so the matrix m is mapped to the matrix
r m r transposed by some rotation r
now
one thing you could do for this type of
data is to to build a globally rotation
equivalent network as we saw before
um in previous lectures but this might
not be the best idea because
this this brain data is typically
registered which means that it's always
in the same
upright orientation and it's always
centered in the image
and so you would never see the same
brain
uh globally rotated
but at small scales
it can very well be that the same
patterns
occur
in every possible orientation so it
makes sense to assume that local
directions
should be considered equivalent
and
another way to say that is that all
orthogonal frames
that you can attach at a local position
should be equivalent
so
um
we can model that by uh by uh
as gauge transformations with with the
values in the in the
uh
you know installed
mostly
uh if you then impose gauge equivariance
as we'll look at in a second uh what it
would do is is make sure that your
filters are
locally rotation equivalent uh which are
without imposing global constraints
right so what is so what do we mean by
gauge acting variance
uh well here we have uh on the bottom
left
a uh vector field represented
relative to the standard gauge for for
the plane and a particular coordinate
system
um
we know what it needs to do a gauge
transformation that's indicated by the
horizontal arrow there we apply an
independent rotation to every uh frame
uh and uh
that will lead to a change in the
numerical representation of our vector
field even though the vectors themselves
remain the same
then we can apply a layer of our network
uh indicated here by f
uh that applies some kind of processing
on this data
here it's of course a very simplistic
example we have a vector field pointing
in one direction and our layer flips it
around to to not to be in another
direction
of course
in real applications your network would
learn to do
much more interesting things
but here
then we can apply a gauge transformation
to the output
uh and what we would like is that the
gauge transformation of the output
is is numerically the same as applying
gauge transformation to the input and
then applying the same network layer f
if
if the network satisfies this we say
that it's gauge at convergence
okay so so far we've looked at what are
called external gauge symmetries where
the frame of reference
is
a frame for the tangent space of the
of the manifold
and
when you talk to physicists uh who are
really the the main ones who use this
word
gauge gauge and gauge transformation
they typically think about something
else namely uh internal gauge symmetries
and uh these are mathematically quite
similar but but still different so in
this case case of internal gauge
symmetries
the
basis vectors of your gauge of your
frame are not
related in any way to the
directions in the
in the manifold or
uh uh domain omega
so here is one example there are many
examples in physics uh that i don't know
that much about uh but uh and also they
don't play uh as of yet
a very important role in applications of
geometric deep learning
but
um
here's one example so what we can do is
uh
look at a single rgb vector so that's
the fiber at a particular point
in the plane
r3
and
we
we can say that a
you know we have the r g and b basis
vectors and we could for example permute
them by the action of the permutation
group on three elements
and we could call that a gauge
transformation if we do that separately
at each location
uh then we're changing the numerical
representation of the image but if we
remember that the uh order
of the color channels that each pixel uh
is now different it's still the same
image
um
and to say that this should be again
seen as a gauge symmetry uh means that
you get a constraint on your filters
uh that
that may that make it so that uh you get
weight sharing between different uh
color channels and all color channels
are then processed uh equivalently
i hope that's somewhat clear um
this isn't to say this is particularly
useful but i hope to to illustrate the
the concept of an internal gauge
symmetry which may find find its
application in geometric deep learning
someday
all right so we've looked at feature
fields as one motivation for looking at
this notion of gauges
there's another one
which
which is important in geometric deep
learning which is when we ask the
question how can we
generalize this notion of convolution
which has been so you know successful in
uh in
you know let's call it classical deep
learning
how can we generalize that to manifolds
or other kinds of spaces
now we've already seen various kinds of
generalizations
of convolution and these were mainly
um following the the the following
philosophy so
you define a filter at some position
in your space let's say you put a filter
on the north pole
of a sphere
and then you use
symmetries from the symmetry group of
the underlying space omega say the
sphere
in order to map to to move that filter
over your space so you can do that in
the plane shifting a filter over a plane
or shifting and rotating it
you can do it on the sphere and you can
in fact do it on any kind of homogeneous
space so what was that again a
homogeneous space
is a space like the sphere where for any
two points there exists a symmetry that
maps one into the other and so what that
means is if you apply these symmetries
to your filter
you can take a filter defined in one
position and move it to any other
position
and that gives you global weight sharing
and something that looks a lot like a
convolution
however there are plenty of manifolds
that are not homogeneous spaces
and so you can think of an arbitrary
wobbly space or a shape of a human
figure or some other
mesh or manifold
and usually it's not a homogeneous space
here you see an example that's kind of
in between
it's a space that has some symmetry
uh we can apply certain discrete
rotations to the icosahedron
and that will map it back onto itself so
those are symmetries
and those would for example take the
filter here the blue one defined on this
corner and allow you to map that filter
to any other corner
of the icosahedron and we could then use
that to do weight sharing among the
filters on the different corners but
since there are not enough symmetries
here we can't use that to map this
filter to let's say an internal face or
some position on an edge so you don't
get enough weight sharing
in this case if you follow this strategy
and in the general case where there may
be no global symmetries you get no
weight sharing at all
so
this strategy for generalizing
convolutions doesn't work anymore
for these uh
non-homogeneous spaces
then there was another idea uh which is
that maybe we can share filters
by uh parallel transport
um and this is an interesting idea and
one that we we
that that nowadays is still uh uh part
of the solution that people prefer but
uh there are some subtleties associated
with it so let's say we have a
uh
a filter defined here on the the front
of the sphere
where the black arrow is drawn
and let's say
we want to parallel transport it
uh according to either this curve or
this curve uh
to uh
um to place this filter in different
positions
uh what you see is that depending on
which curve you choose either the one
with the red arrows or the one with the
blue arrows when you by the time you
arrive on the opposite side of the
sphere the arrows are pointing in
completely opposite
directions
and uh
so what that means is that
just saying that you're going to take a
filter define a one canonical position
and then parallel transport it to every
other position is not enough because you
need to now specify again something
completely arbitrary which is the path
by which you transport it and depending
on the path you choose you're going to
end up with a filter
that is
completely arbitrarily oriented
depending on which path you choose
so here's another
way to visualize this in the classical
case of convolution on a flat space
we can take a filter to find uh here
let's say call this the the origin
and then no matter how we shift it to
another position the orientation of the
filter is always going to remain the
same so that's a property of the
parallel transport on a flat space but
when you consider a curved space
this is no longer true so here you see a
cube and you may think it's a bit odd to
call that a curved space but you could
think of it as a
sphere where we
squashed all the curvature into the
corners
so in this case
when we take the filter this find here
in the center of the the front face and
we we sort of shift it without rotating
that is to say with parallel transported
to this face here on the right and then
to the top
or we transform to the top via by just
going there directly via this green
arrow
uh we end up with two filters on the top
face that are oriented relative to each
other by or you know transformed by 90
degree
rotation so again you see that the this
this path dependence uh becomes
important
um
so uh so yeah that's that's an issue
now
uh one way to address this um
arbitrariness of the orientation of the
filter
is to just choose filters that don't
really have an orientation so this is a
a
an idea that was one of the the first
ideas on how to do convolution on a
manifold that was explored in the
geometric deep learning literature
um
yeah
basically the idea is to use isotropic
filters like this filters that don't
have any directional sensitivity
and if you squint a little bit this is
also similar to
the simplest kind of graph neural
networks where you use the same weights
for
processing messages coming from each
adjacent edge
then a more advanced idea is uh what's
called the geodesic convolution by
muskie
and with michael bronstein and claire
underguidance
so here the idea is that at each
position p in your space omega you're
going to extract a local patch and look
at the signal
on that patch
and then you're going to take inner
products with rotated copies
of a filter
so that's quite similar to what we saw
in the lecture on group convolution you
take a filter you apply it you just
apply it in every orientation and then
you get a whole bunch of responses for
different orientations of the filter at
each position and in the representation
theoretic or steerable cnn way of
looking at this this would be called
scalar to regular
operation
scalar
representation to a regular
representation
and now in order to iterate this
procedure to apply the next layer to
apply non-linearities and then the next
layer of geodesic convolution
you would
have to do max pooling over orientations
uh in order to get
to get a quantity that's invariant
to the orientation of the original
filter which as we've seen
has to be chosen in an arbitrary way
so that's a that's a a good idea um now
we can detect directionally sensitive
features like this edge detector here
but the features that you have after max
pooling
are still orientation insensitive in
that they can only indicate that there
is
let's say an edge at this location but
not what orientation it has so it has to
you know you're still losing information
by by cooling
um so that's
uh where uh gauge equivalent networks
coming
so here the uh general idea uh again
follows the very much the geometric deep
learning blueprint as described in our
book
so
we first define for each layer a feature
space so we have our space omega in this
case typically a manifold and we attach
the feature space see the fight or the
fiber in the mathematical theory of this
stuff
uh
this
uh fiber this features
space comes with a transformation law or
group representation for example a
vector transforms differently from two
tensors in diffusion tensor imaging and
those will transform differently from a
scalar
as in a grayscale image
and this determines how gauge
transformations act on the feature
vectors
then our feature space is the space of
fields of those types of geometrical
quantities over omega
and then we see we we are looking for a
convolution layer that's gauge
equivalent so if we perform a gauge
transformation for example if we
uh
orient our filter relative to gauge we
transform the gauge the filter will will
be transformed will be rotated for
example
and we want that the output coefficients
then change accordingly
so the simplest case is the one where
our input signal is a scalar signal and
the output signal is also a scalar
signal
uh so we have our yeah we have again our
signal x on omega real valued and we
have a filter
uh that
uh is defined uh
in some
well usually it's parameterized on the
tangent plane so it's a function on the
tangent plane that's mapped to the to
the manifold
uh by the exponential map
and it's oriented relative to gauge
and then you define the the gauge
equivalent convolution by integrating
over the local patch
parameterized by the the tangent plane
coordinates
yeah the product of the signal and the
filter
now
one can prove that uh this type of
operation is gauge equivalent if and
only if the filter is isotropic so
that's again an instance of this
phenomenon we've observed that if your
input is a scalar signal your output is
a scalar signal then the filter has to
be isotropic which is quite undesirable
in general
so then there's a more general type of
operation where now your signal
is a field
represented relative to some choice of
gauge you can think of it as a
vector valued function
a filter is then
a matrix valued uh function
and uh
the basic you know the rest of the
structure is very similar but the basic
result now is that
this is gauging comparing if and only if
the filter satisfies a certain
equivalence constraint and i recommend
looking at the the literature on gauge
variant networks if you if you want to
see the details of this derivation
yeah okay i'm going to skip over the
implementation details
um because there are by now quite a lot
of different ways of implementing this
you know what i've covered in this
lecture is mainly the underlying
theoretical ideas
but when it comes to implementing this
there are many choices
and they're also by now quite a lot of
applications so
this is one of the early works on
applying this to problems in physics
uh
sampling using s-u-n gauge equivalent
flows
uh applications to lattice gauge theory
so these are physics application
[Music]
um
and as i mentioned by now there's
there's a you know much larger
literature so if you're into interested
in physics applications uh check out
these papers and also the papers that
cite them
on the theory side uh
maurice weiler has an interesting paper
on coordinate independence convolutional
networks which covers a lot of the same
material and has a lot of nice
illustrations to explain these ideas
uh and there are various other works
that also cover this this material
uh so then as i mentioned there there is
a lot of mathematical theory uh behind
this called the theory of fiber bundles
which i will not
go into now
right but i did want to share with you
this slide
which hopefully will put uh the
different methods that we've discussed
uh in this course uh into perspective
so
we all know the uh the good old uh
convolutional network on uh for planar
signals or three-dimensional
euclidean signals
and then we looked first at
a generalization called group
convolution
which we could extend all the way to
signals on general homogeneous spaces
spaces where the symmetry group can take
you from any point to any other point
uh and we looked at it for for scalar
signals uh so so uh the case where the
the the geometric the features attached
at each point are not affected by the
transformations like rgb vectors
then we looked at the generalization
called steerable cnns where now you're
still looking at a homogeneous space but
you can consider more general kinds of
fields
vector fields tensor fields etc
um and then we looked at convolutional
nets on manifolds like
romanian manifolds uh the
we have the geodesic convolution for
example and then we looked at finally
engaged cnns which is a
in a
very general framework uh that can deal
with global as well as gauge symmetries
on uh general manufactures
uh so that's it for today thank you for
your attention and i'm happy to take
questions